familiares y amigos despidieron a t banc
y escobar más de tres horas caminaron a
través del municipio de galeana en nuevo
león para darle el último adiós a la
joven mexicana de 18 años desaparecida
el 9 de abril el padre de de bani exige
justicia y rechazo que dejaran libre al
taxista que según vídeos de la fiscalía
la acosó sexualmente para luego dejarla
abandonada en horas de la noche en una
carretera
porque no hasta la persona
le digo aquí está la persona agraviada
que quieres que me lo lleva muerta para
el caso y la acción de las autoridades
ha desatado el descontento social
muchas
el padre denuncia poca transparencia en
las investigaciones luego que el equipo
de búsqueda rastreará en cuatro
oportunidades la misma zona para
encontrar el cuerpo de la joven y que lo
hallaran en solo hasta el pasado jueves
pondremos todos los recursos en nuestras
manos para determinar los hechos que han
sucedido
si estos indican un delito serán
perseguidos con toda la fuerza de la ley
en nuevo léon cinco mujeres han sido
asesinadas y 26 han desaparecido en lo
que va de este año en el país según
datos oficiales en los últimos siete
años se han registrado cerca de cinco
mil 700 víctimas de feminicidio y
17.620 de homicidio doloso lo que indica
que en promedio 9 mujeres son asesinadas
y cada día en mexico